okay we are good to go so let's go ahead
and jump right in so this may look a
little bit familiar for those of you who
shared your experiences and for those of
you who shared your job search
strategies so this is what most job
seekers do this is the approach that
most people take to their job search and
I call this the reactive approach
because if you know kind of the
difference between being reactive and
proactive it's kind of like something
happens and then you react to it so you
act upon a stimulus of some sort being
proactive is more so putting things in
place so that when opportunities do
arise you're ready for it so this is the
reactive approach this is why I see most
people in general not just Udacity
students but they find a job opening
whether it's on LinkedIn or in deed or
Glassdoor or zip recruiter or angel list
or any of these job boards that people
are using to find those jobs one thing I
want to mention is that these job boards
are not necessarily places where jobs
are automatically uploaded to these
companies have to pay these companies in
order to advertise so they're not just
necessarily job boards they're more so
advertising platforms so if a company
doesn't want to pay for that advertising
then that job may may not be posted so
we'll talk about some strategies for
finding those roles that may not be
posted but this is the strategy that
most people take and it's not very
effective it has been in the past and
you will still have some success so if
you're if you're finding jobs online and
applying you still may hear back from
some of them but for the most part I
hear this and I've experienced it
personally that this just does not work
too well and part of that is due to how
a lot of companies are going about
finding the the top talent and the
candidates for these roles which will
cover that as well so that you have an
understanding of what to do but also so
that you have an understanding of what
these employers are looking for because
from my experience it's helpful to put
yourself in the mindset of somebody
who's hiring so that you know why they
make the decisions that they make so if
you're applying
for a hundred jobs and you're getting
generic responses from every one of
those hopefully I can help you
understand what's going on there um
let's go ahead and move forward if you
are taking this strategy we're gonna
work on fixing that it's no shame to
anybody who is I did it for a very long
time and I did not experience much
success from it and so this was a
learning opportunity for me as well
before I really started to learn how to
go about this and understand the hiring
process and figure out how to be more
proactive about my own job search in my
career as a whole so let's talk about
why applying online is ineffective so
this is like you know using like you're
indeed your LinkedIn
Glassdoor these different job boards and
even sometimes the individual company's
website can be a little bit ineffective
when you're just submitting a resume and
applying online so this statistic it
tends to change depending on the
organization that's doing the research
but what I've found kind of you know a
comprehensive of all of those different
things I found that between 70 to 85
percent of jobs are not even posted
online so when you're thinking about you
know applying for jobs online it may
shift your perspective a little bit to
find out that the majority of jobs that
people are getting and the majority of
jobs that employers are looking to fill
are not posted on those websites one of
those reasons is because they have to
pay for and it can be very expensive but
there are a lot of other reasons that go
into it which we'll talk about further
on down the next thing is that most
larger companies use what's called an
applicant tracking system so some of you
is anybody familiar with the applicant
tracking system I know sometimes people
know what I'm talking about sometimes I
don't this will not be an in-depth
tutorial on what that is but I would
definitely encourage you to do some
independent research on what that is
especially for all of you in tech it is
a software platform
I'll give you kind of a high-level
description of what it is so basically
an applicant tracking system is a
software program that companies pay for
and utilize to process job
and so how most of them work is when you
upload a job let's say for example a
company is looking for a digital
marketer and the job description will
kind of list the roles and
responsibilities as well as the
description of the position and what
that applicant tracking system does is
it scans that job description for
keywords and so a lot of keywords that
may come up for a digital marketing
position might be social media
management measuring insights email
marketing platforms like MailChimp or
HubSpot or Salesforce or anything like
that that may be required to perform
well in a digital marketing role those
software programs are going to scan for
those words that come up more frequently
so you can even do this on your own
as you're going through job descriptions
if you see that the word
machine-learning pops up in a job
description five times you'll want to
make sure that your resume has that
listed on there about as many times
because what that applicant tracking
system also does is it compares your
resume to that job description and so it
measures the I guess the it measures a
match based on how well your keywords
from your resume fit the job description
it's a horrible system it's terrible
it's measuring people's ability to
perform well in a role based on their
ability to include the same keywords
from the job description so I absolutely
hate applying for jobs online even when
this is done effectively incorrectly you
still have a chance of having a lower
quality score on those applicant
tracking systems because it can be
difficult to match certain keywords
without compromising the quality of your
application materials and so this is
another reason why applying online is
ineffective and from what I'm seeing in
the chat a lot of you weren't even
familiar with what applicant tracking
systems are and so a lot of you are
applying for jobs without tailoring your
resume to fit and that's probably why
you are not even getting first-round
interviews why you are getting those
generic you know thank you we decided to
move on with other candidates and so
this like I said this is not going to be
an
/ like an in-depth overview of what
applicant tracking systems are so I
would definitely encourage you look on
YouTube some of them have very cool like
graphics where they show with like
little cartoons and different things
that I explain it a little bit better
than I'm going to today because I want
to talk about some other reasons my goal
today is not to teach you how to apply
to jobs better online my goal here today
is to teach you some other strategies
but if you are going to continue
applying for jobs online which is fine I
would just encourage you to not make
that your main strategy but if you are
going to do it please make sure that
you're doing it correctly so let's see
what people are saying in the chat I'm
so like Glassdoor let's see recruiters
put your resume into the 80s and
magically it will tell if you're good
for the position or not they decide to
call you whether or not based on those
results so it is it's it's a terrible
system and even the people that use it
know it's a horrible system but let me
help you understand why so as technology
has evolved everything that we do in the
business process evolved so that
includes hiring so with the like
introduction of online applications that
means you can apply for any job from
anywhere at any time with any background
skills and experiences and so the
recruiters and these employers just
simply don't have the capability to
review as many resumes as they're
receiving so they've had to implement
these applicant tracking systems to
somewhat filter out people who have no
business even applying for those jobs
and I can attest to that as somebody who
has hired in the past at my previous
full-time position there were people who
applied for every single position at the
company and so they were by no means
qualified for most of them and so some
of these systems are put into place to
kind of find people who are a little bit
more qualified so I don't want to spend
too much time on that that's for another
topic for you all to kind of research on
your own or maybe we'll do a an
additional webinar on that but I want to
make sure that you all are utilizing
other strategies than just simply
applying online
okay so and then the last bullet point
here is that employers prefer to hire
people with relevant experience and
through referrals so this is probably
one of the number one probably top two
or three issues that I see from Udacity
students they're completing nano degree
programs but they have no direct
experience and that's just a really
tough situation to get around I
previously facilitated a webinar on that
topic so it's gaining experience when
nobody will hire you if you check the
Udacity z-- YouTube page there's an
entire playlist of all of our previously
recorded webinars so that one will be on
there if you want to look into finding
opportunities to gain some experience
outside of you know just getting a job
if you're hearing that people say we
want you to have more experience that's
a great resource for you to check out if
you're looking for a little bit more
in-depth insight on how you can start
developing some experience there and
then referrals so as I mentioned in the
beginning referrals are the key to
really landing a job especially in 2020
it is by far the most successful way of
landing in interviews as well as landing
jobs so let's talk a little bit more
about that so with referrals the reason
why I want to kind of stress this is
because people don't realize that
relationships make the world go round
it's you can't have a successful
business without building relationships
you can't you know really perform a
successful job search without
relationships unless you get lucky you
know even with dating you you that's all
about relationships it's all about how
you are connecting to people and so that
does not change for the job search
process so here just a couple of things
a couple of statistics that I wanted to
share to help drive home the importance
of this right so one study showed that
on average you have about a two percent
chance of landing an interview when
applying for jobs online that's terrible
that is extremely low to landed in
you that's not even to land a job and so
obviously your your chances of landing
that actual job are much much lower this
is not to say that people can't be
successful doing this this is not to say
that each and every one of you have a 2%
chance remember this is an average so
for most applicants you have about a 2%
chance on average to land an interview
when applying that alone is enough for
me to want to like figure out okay well
what what else another statistic on
average only about 7% of people who are
applying for jobs include those
applications with employee referrals so
we're talking about the importance of
this and how important it is but only 7%
of people are actually doing it so now
where all of this comes together is that
referrals account for about 40% of all
hires so people who are hired on average
for any given job about 40% of those
people are coming directly as a result
of referrals this is the highest
percentage as it relates to you know
landing a job obviously forty percent is
not a hundred percent or eighty or
ninety so other things that factor into
that include hiring internally so maybe
you already work for a company and they
hire you within some of that percentage
is accounted for through job boards some
of that percentage is accounted for
through career fairs other hiring events
and different things like that but as of
right now referrals are the way to go if
you want to land a job and especially if
you want to land a good job with a good
company and part of this reason why
employers and recruiters are so heavy
heavily emphasizing referrals is that on
average referral people who are referred
to a job tend to stay at that job longer
they tend to cost less in the process
because of the there's not a need to
advertise those jobs and they tend to
perform better and so for me as a job
seeker I also have to put myself in the
position of an employer and say if I'm
trying to make a smart business decision
why would I filter through hundreds of
online applications when I know that the
people who are referred are more likely
to be better employees save us money and
stay in the position longer so
I hope some of this is encouraging you
to start thinking about okay maybe I
should stop spending so much time
applying for jobs online and maybe start
exploring some of these other strategies
let's see what's going on in the chat
okay so somebody got their first job
from a contest and university contests
how to get work experience when nobody
will hire us there's a webinar I'll try
to include that link towards the end if
you want to stay tuned but yeah I did a
whole hour-long webinar about that but I
understand that that's a real pain point
but let's keep it moving so this is the
job search strategy that I want you to
start utilizing a little bit more so if
you want to feel free to either take a
screenshot you can also you know maybe
just snap a picture on your phone but
this is what I would I would love for
you all to start at least attempting to
do and this is what I call the proactive
approach because this is you doing this
in advance so that you know this this
cycle continues so you're not awareness
apply awareness apply there's a lot
other steps that you can take in order
to start getting some of these referrals
so step one this is usually the first
step that I give people when they have
their first coaching call with me is to
have an idea of which companies you want
to work for so a lot of people are just
kind of going about it blindly they're
searching for job titles let's say they
want a data analyst job they're just
searching for data analysts and applying
for any of those that fit them they're
not specifically targeting companies and
so it's extremely difficult for them to
land referrals based on you know just
applying for jobs online and not doing
anything else so your first step is to
target companies so as your do as you're
going through this process you need to
be realistic about where you fit in in
the competition as well I get a lot of
people who will say you know I was
qualified for the job I interviewed well
and I still didn't get it that happens
the same way LeBron James doesn't win
every single basketball game it is not
always about you not being qualified for
the job sometimes it's just about the
level of competition that you're
competing with and so this is why it's
extremely important for you to target
these companies first so that you can be
more intentional about the strategies
that you're implementing with those
specific companies so
you need to be able to figure out one
what types of positions that you're
gonna be applying for you shouldn't be
taking on four or five completely
different nano degrees and saying I'm
open to whatever you should be if you're
going to do that you need to have
targeted approaches for each one of
those jobs that you want but that first
step is for you to figure out which
companies do I want to apply for and
then going back so my first point you
have to be realistic about where you
stand in the competition if you have no
college degree no internships no work
experience that's related to the field
that you want to go into if all you have
is a nano degree in no direct work
experience you getting a job at Apple or
Google or Tesla or these high-level tech
companies that a lot of people want is
going to be it's gonna be it's gonna be
very very difficult it's going to be
especially difficult if you don't have
people to refer you as well so you have
to be realistic about where your skill
set is and so if you do have a lot of
work experience if you do have the
education to back it up then I would say
that you have a better chance for some
of those roles but if you are just kind
of starting off or you're making a
career change keep your mind open to
working for smaller companies keep your
mind open to working for startups keep
your mind open to doing an internship
keep your mind open to taking a pay cut
if it means that you get to start in an
industry that you're more passionate
about so those are just a couple things
that I want to go over because I feel
like people only want to work for these
kind of sexy companies and these these
really cool companies in these jobs but
you also have to have the experience and
the credentials to back that up ok so
moving on once you target those
companies now you can start finding
strategic connections so whether that's
through LinkedIn is a great tool for you
to start doing this so let's say for
example you want to work for XYZ company
what you can do on LinkedIn is search
that company and then filter by their
employees and then find people who are
working at that company who are doing
the types of work that you want to do
where I see a lot of people fail here is
they
only reach out to recruiters or they'll
only reach out to like Steel's or
directors or management level people and
those people aren't actually doing the
work that you want to do so I would
highly recommend that you're reaching
out to the people who have the positions
that you want because one they're gonna
be able to provide you with better
insight into what it's like working
there but they also may have a direct
impact on the hiring decision or could
advocate for you as you start going for
these jobs so LinkedIn is a great tool
but also if you are out at networking
events or you're attending meetups this
can be great because if you find
somebody who works for that company feel
free to share that you know hey that's
that's on the list of my top kind of six
companies that I really want to work for
I'd love to take you out to coffee or
buy you lunch or just you know schedule
some time for us to just chat one-on-one
so it's important for you to have a plan
because if you don't you're just kind of
wandering aimlessly and you don't have
any type of strategy for how you're
going to put yourself in a position for
that so going back to there's this
networking idea you're going to want to
have some face-to-face interaction for
those people who solely want to do their
networking online that's fine and that
work sometimes but there's a certain
power that comes with having that
face-to-face interaction being able to
showcase to somebody that not only are
you great with data science you can
actually have a genuine conversation
with somebody who you might be working
with so that's really important for you
to make sure that you're attending
events that you're getting out there and
you're connecting with people so another
resource is Meetup
that's a great resource I know a lot of
people who have had a lot of success
with that so it's meetup comm or you can
use the app Meetup I know for the most
part this is mainly us-based so I don't
know if they have a lot of international
presence if they do great if not once
again do some of your own independent
research for your specific geographic
location if there are any types of
groups maybe even Facebook groups that
meet face to face in person to where you
can start connecting with people in your
industry and you can start you know
building these relationships with
like-minded people who are also doing
the same work that you want to do or can
potentially help you land your next role
so let's see some of these questions
how does foreign versus local experience
work so that's gonna be different with
with every company that you apply for so
there are gonna be some companies who
are kind of like I'm staying away from
any type of international hires because
we don't have the capability to do so
there may be people who do that because
they just they can't there may be people
who do that because they don't want to
there may be people who are actually
looking for people with international
experience and there may be people who
were kind of like you know if it fits it
fits and so that's why I talk about this
job search process is more of an art
than a science because ultimately people
are making these decisions it's not an
algorithm it's not a formula they're not
putting in a bunch of numbers and saying
the person with the top score wins it's
being decided by people so it's it's
hard to give really any definitive
answers for certain questions like that
once again if you have questions please
try to keep them on topic if you have
any questions towards the end
please save those that may be a little
bit less relevant to what we're talking
about today but meetups are great for
that one because oftentimes you're
you're all coming together on a specific
subject so there's a group that I'm
involved in here in Atlanta Georgia
and it's called technologists of color
and so it's a technology group so I know
that I'm not gonna go to an event and
speak to people who are you know
necessarily in human resources or sales
or anything like that these people are
gonna be in text so we already have that
in common
the other great thing about it is that
it these meetups oftentimes meet on a
consistent basis so that makes it easier
for that relationship building because
you're seeing the same people on a
consistent basis you don't necessarily
have to worry too much about doing your
own individual follow-up so moving on is
personal branding this is my jam right
here this is what
I enjoy helping people do more than
anything because it leads to so many
different opportunities when you're able
to do it well but this is a lot about
things like posting on LinkedIn things
about conducting workshops showing up to
these events people know who you are
people know what you do writing articles
getting featured in blogs these types of
things this personal branding piece is
so powerful and I promise you it's not
as difficult as you might think I think
I started with it about two years ago I
really started pushing this so I started
putting out a lot more content on
LinkedIn I started connecting with
people in person I started doing public
speaking I started doing webinars with
Udacity as well as outside but really
just speaking on my subject matter
expertise which is job searching and
career coaching so for you this may
involve anything that you're learning
that you want to go into so if you want
to if you want to work in AI start
posting about that on LinkedIn start
reading articles and providing your own
feedback create your own posts what's
worked really well for me is taking a
how-to approach that is is kind of like
what I've found to work for me so
sometimes it's a little bit about
figuring out what works for you I spoke
to one Udacity student and we had a
great conversation he was I believe he
was studying front-end development and
he was living in Silicon Valley but he
was driving uber and so he was talking
about having all of these conversations
with people who were working at these
tech companies who he was picking up and
driving around and so one of the
strategies that we came up with for him
was to actually document some of these
quote unquote interviews and share this
information out for other people who
were looking for jobs in tech and so
there are so many different creative
ways that you can go about personal
branding so where you're helping
yourself but you're also helping other
people because for him he's helping any
job seeker in the Silicon Valley area
land these jobs by talking directly to
people who are already doing it so that
was just one kind of really cool example
but then I also
have people who are working on writing
articles on their subject matter area so
that they have a better understanding of
how they can showcase to people that
they know what they're doing that they
know what they talk they're talking
about somebody says how much time do you
spend on personal branding weekly um it
depends week to week I think for me I
spend more time on that than any of
these other areas just because I've
gotten a solid handle on it at this
point I'm getting paid to do it now so
it's almost like doing my own PR even
with this webinar even though I'm doing
this on behalf of Udacity you know some
people will watch this they may connect
with me on LinkedIn and say oh Brett he
works for Udacity he's an expert in job
search coaching so it really depends on
the week it depends on what I'm doing
but I spend a lot of time writing I
spend a lot of time creating content and
I spend a lot of time doing public
speaking and workshops so for me it's a
very big area that I focus on because
it's led to so many different
opportunities for me how important is
consistent and see when it comes to
creating content and put on LinkedIn its
consistency is key consistency is key
with everything but especially creating
content on LinkedIn because if you're
doing well if your posts are getting
engagement you want to keep that
momentum going if you have an article
that does really well follow that up
with a couple of brief posts that maybe
pull snippets from that article or if
you did get a chance to attend an event
you know take pictures provide a recap
brag on the speaker that's something
that I do all the time if I'm trying to
think of like content to post I'll go to
an event take a picture and say you know
this was an amazing event tagged that
person lists all the different things
that I've learned it helps them to boost
their visibility it helps me to boost my
visibility and it helps my followers to
learn something that they weren't able
to attend so as it relates to this
personal branding piece and utilizing
LinkedIn try to find ways where
everybody wins that's where I see people
have the most success on LinkedIn is
where they're helping somebody helping
themselves and then helping the general
public who are getting to see that
interaction so that's kind of my piece
on personal branding there also to dip
webinars that I facilitated with Udacity
on LinkedIn specifically so within that
career webinars playlist so if you don't
know what I'm talking about I can't drop
it in the chat just yet
I will towards the end but if you want
to kind of find it on your own just go
to youtube search Udacity go to their
Channel and then there will be a
playlist for career webinars so if
you're enjoying this presentation feel
free to look through all of those
different topics and see if anything
stands out and appeals to you but there
are two specific webinars that focus on
LinkedIn that I facilitated that will
really help you with this personal
branding piece if you're also active or
looking for more information on this in
student hub we each coach posts weekly
tips every week and so this week is
actually my week I'm gonna post another
tip after this but my week of tips is
focused around being recognized as a
subject matter expert so a lot of it
will be also talking about kind of this
personal branding piece that we're
talking about okay and then kind of this
last step is the awareness of the job
opening and applying for it so once
you're kind of going through this
process then you find a job opening at
that point is so much easier to say hey
Brett I saw that you have an opening for
a digital marketing position I'm
wondering if you could put in a referral
for me or I'm wondering if you could
forward my application materials to the
hiring manager what most people do is
honestly they're lazy they're lazy and
they're using people and so that's why
they don't have success when they're
doing this process wrong they don't
focus on this right here they don't
focus on the building relationships
piece and that's where they fail some
people will find a job first and then
try to reach out and at that point it
becomes very transactional it's hey I
saw this job I want your help to get it
for me on the receiving end
that's not appealing to me that's not
appealing to me to necessarily want to
help you because it seems like all
you're doing is using me to get a job
and a lot of people will have that same
mentality in that same mindset and so
that's why you want to be as proactive
as possible with this process and so
even if you are in a point where you
need a job now this
this is still gonna find you a good job
faster than just applying to any job
here and there if it's smaller companies
you'll definitely have more success so
once again I don't want you to I don't
want to discourage you completely from
applying for jobs online because some of
those smaller companies are still using
this process but if we're talking like
the good jobs the good companies the
higher paying roles those are gonna be
highly competitive and so that's where
this stuff comes in to be very important
one other thing is you may even get
reached out to by that person so if you
have a good relationship with that
person hopefully you've clearly
communicated how they can help you and
what you're looking for in terms of jobs
this has happened to me there was a
position that I I wanted a couple years
ago first thing I targeted that company
I knew I wanted to work for this company
so I started looking for strategic
connections so I went on LinkedIn and
we're looking through employees that
we're doing the role that I wanted it
was a campus recruiter position and so I
found three different people who were
campus recruiters at that company and I
found one person who had a similar
background as me so my background is in
higher education and I saw that he had a
very similar background so then I
reached out to him that networking piece
and I said hey I noticed that you are
working here in this role I'm really
interested in potentially doing this
someday
I see that you have a similar background
and I'm really interested to know how
you made that transition from this to
this
I'd love to schedule some time to chat
with you meet over coffee if you have
the time or if you're interested and so
what happened was we met we had a
conversation I continued to stay in
communication with him just quick
check-ins like hey thank you so much for
meeting with me I really appreciate it
it helped me to figure out this this and
this and then that personal branding
piece came in and so I started putting
out a lot more content around recruiting
and recruiting college students and
helping college students find jobs and
so that person started to see my face
and my name attached to my subject
matter expertise a lot more often and so
when his co-worker got a new job he
reached out to me immediately
or the position was even posted remember
going back to the beginning 70 to 85
percent of jobs are not even posted
online and so he reached out to me and
asked me to send him my application
materials so I didn't even have to apply
for that job online my role here with
Udacity as a career coach I never had to
apply for this job online most of that
started here within the personal
branding area but because I was posting
about career coaching and job search
assistance a recruiter from there saw
the work that I was doing they saw that
I had similar experience and they asked
me to if I wanted to interview for the
position and that's how I got this role
so just a couple of stories to showcase
to you like this is not just me sharing
something that I think this is what
actually works because it's centrally
focused around relationships and
building relationships and getting out
there and meeting people and trying to
connect I know we live in a as connected
as we are as a global society we still
oftentimes just kind of hide behind our
phones or hide behind our computers but
really getting out in person is where
you start to develop some of those solid
relationships that can lead to not only
jobs but opportunities for you know
freelance work opportunities for paid
writing gigs opportunities for public
speaking you never really know what can
happen there there have been times where
people have brought me in to do like
very quick consulting work I'm currently
writing for a blog right now I've
written for another blog and I do
workshops all the time and all of this
is coming from a lot of that personal
branding stuff and putting out content
around my subject matter area okay so
once again drill this into your brain
that try to focus on this these two down
here are kind of the biggest areas for
you to get referrals so that's what you
want to focus on but really this whole
area is gonna be important so let's move
on I did not expect that to talk take
too long but I'm curious to know what
companies are you targeting if any so if
you are let us know in the chat if
you're not you should be something to
think about moving forward not a problem
if you haven't
it will help you moving forward so I'm
curious to know what types of companies
you all are looking for while you start
typing that in give me one second I'm
going to make sure I plugged up my
laptop so we're good here
okay let's see small tech companies okay
that's good that's good that you know
Google Amazon Adobe Microsoft okay those
are those are up there you better be
very prepared um let's see top tall up
work
the future Facebook Amazon okay product
based companies tech companies companies
Google Microsoft Microsoft Amazon so
this chat is extremely helpful right now
because it's helping me to understand
this but for you all to think in this
chat alone right there are 62 people on
this webinar right now there are
probably five different people who have
listed Microsoft imagine that on a
global scale the competition is crazy
it's insane the level of competition for
these companies that everybody wants to
work for which makes those referrals and
that networking so much more important
so for those of you who are going for
those jobs I wholeheartedly support you
in going for that I will however
encourage you to open your mindset a
little bit to potential other
opportunities outside of those enormous
companies once again that competition is
going to be very high so don't put all
of your eggs in that basket right don't
focus all of your effort and energy on
those huge companies because you may be
missing out on opportunities from
smaller tech companies or startups
especially if you don't have honestly if
you want to work for those companies you
have to have top-notch experience and
you have to be able to go in and kill
those technical interviews if you feel
confident doing that I say absolutely go
for it but if you're looking for a job
and looking to land a job I would say
don't solely focus on on those major
companies because you could you could
just be missing out on other
opportunities as well as the level of
competition that you have to compete
with this is pretty overwhelming a
couple of people talked about working
remotely those positions are also highly
competitive obviously because of the
flexibility that they offer it
and sometimes be a little bit difficult
to kind of go through that process as
well because it's hard to connect in
person with remote companies and so
LinkedIn can be very helpful there and
that online communication piece is going
to be key so great that's great if you
all have ideas of where you want to work
let me see I think I missed a question
Oh
how do you narrow down to a specific
role to pursue is there a good resource
to help narrow your scope so I wouldn't
say that there's any type of specific
resource one activity that I've
encouraged people to do is to kind of
make like a t-chart of the different
positions that you've had and list all
of the things that you enjoyed and all
the things that you didn't and just
compare those all and see if there are
things in common so if you realize I
liked this job because it allowed me to
work flexibly I liked this job because I
got to work with other people I like
this job because they really supported
professional development and sending
people to conferences the one thing I
didn't like is that there was a little
bit of lack of work-life balance this
that and the other once you start
looking at the commonalities between the
jobs and experiences that you've had in
the things that you like and the things
that you dislike start trying to find
roles that fit more of the things that
you do like and the things that are
gonna be more impactful to creating the
lifestyle that you want to live as you
speak to different coaches as you hear
from different coaches a lot of us we
share different we share similar
strategies in terms of this process but
as it relates to career coaching some of
us have different mindsets going into it
for me I used to be really big on you
know get up and do what you love and
enjoy that and I think that I still kind
of pull on that but for me it's more so
now about utilizing your career to
create the lifestyle that you want to
live so if you're okay with not having
that much money but you just want to
work a little bit less there are
opportunities for that if you are really
just focused on maybe you want to buy a
house and you're okay with working with
you're okay with working wherever
because it means that you're gonna get
the financial means to be able to buy
that house I'm
big on creating opportunities for
yourself based on the goals that you
have not necessarily letting your career
dictate how you're able to live your
life and so that's that's really my
mindset around it and that's how I go
about it right now the reason why I was
so interested in this job specifically
was because it was part-time I got to
create my hours and it allowed me to
build my business while I really wanted
to do that and so keep those things in
mind as well as it relates to trying to
narrow down your scope for the roles
that you're looking for anything
specific when it comes to applying to
remote jobs there is a webinar that that
I did recently on that one I need to
make sure that that one gets uploaded
but that's that's a whole other topic
that that's too long for me to try to
answer right now okay let me get back to
the presentation and I'll try to get
back to some of those questions that we
weren't able to get to so let's talk
about networking a relationship building
right so we talked about this a little
bit but let's continue to let's continue
to brainstorm around this topic so in
person as I mentioned is extremely
important extremely beneficial meetup is
great for that another resource is
Eventbrite once again this is more
us-based from my experience so there may
be other websites that are similar in
your geographic location but Eventbrite
most people use for event registration
but you can also use that platform for
browsing for events and searching for
events so if you know anything like that
in your area you can search for tech you
can search for business you can search
for data science you can search for
marketing digital marketing AI all those
things and try to find events one thing
that people don't realize is it doesn't
have to be called a networking event for
you to do effective networking there I
would say probably the more successful
events where I've done networking is at
like workshops so other people who are
also trying to learn a specific subject
I think that's great way to kind of
connect because you share a common
experience together so don't necessarily
look just for networking events panels
launch parties anything like that that
might have people there who are involved
in a similar end
and then online you're gonna keep
hearing me anytime I do a webinar I'm
probably going to push LinkedIn and so
it's so extremely important if you're
not involving this in your job search
strategy right now you're missing out if
you want to schedule a coaching call to
talk about that free feel free to set
that up with me I highly encourage you
to take a look at those two LinkedIn
webinars before scheduling a coaching
call about LinkedIn because I'll just be
providing you with a lot of information
that's on that so if you're able to
watch those two before scheduling a call
we can really hit the ground running and
do some individualized planning and
strategy for that online communities
Facebook groups group me slack channels
email list serves there are a lot of
different ways that you can connect with
people online but then you see that that
little star note at the bottom take
these conversations offline if you can
if you're local or you're maybe visiting
an area where you have online
connections try to meet in person I
can't stress how important that is
because at the end of the day it does
not matter how capable you are of doing
a job you still have to work with people
and on the hiring in I have to like you
as a person to want to work with you for
the most part I would rather hire
somebody I liked with a little bit less
skills than somebody who I don't like or
somebody who can't even have a 30 minute
coffee chat who's just a little bit more
highly skilled because things like that
are a lot more easily trained than it is
to you know genuinely want to work with
somebody so always always always should
be a goal to take the connections that
you're building online into face to face
interactions okay great thank you so
much for posting those links in there so
if you look in the chat those two
linkedin webinars that I was talking
about escena thank you so much for
posting those in there if anybody's
interested you know you can feel free to
open those bookmark them whatever but
those are going to be really helpful for
you in terms of one the first one is
about optimizing your profile that's
step one
most people stop there the second one is
about engagement in content creation and
that's where a lot of that personal
branding in that relationship building
comes in
place so I see a couple more questions
in there but I want to make sure that we
get through the presentation so the next
thing I brought to this back up again
just in case anybody didn't get a chance
to screenshot or take a snap of that
obviously this is gonna be recorded so
if you want to watch the replay it'll be
there as well um okay I see somebody
might have okay um okay so back to this
personal branding piece so I want you
all to start thinking about yourself as
a business whether you freelance whether
you're an entrepreneur or not job
searching is marketing and employers are
your customers so as you go through this
process you have to imagine that you are
a product or you are a service that
people need and so you have to do your
market research you have to have these
one-on-ones with people that work at
this company find out what their needs
are find out what problems they're
currently experiencing so that when you
do write a cover letter or when you do
have that project to complete or when
you do have your technical interview or
when you have your official interview
you can propose solutions to these
things if you think about it every
single job opportunity ever is either a
problem that needs to be solved or a
goal that they want to accomplish and so
if you can showcase to them in before
you even hired how you can solve their
problems how do you compete with that
it's hard to so make sure that you're
doing your research and this is where
you know having that target company
comes into play sin is is a very
important because you can't research
every single company it's better that
you do this with the companies that you
actually want to work for next thing is
is is results-driven branding and so if
you know going back to my example the
jobs I was trying to get were campus
recruiting positions so I was sharing
more content around recruiting top
talent recruiting young talent helping
college students find jobs and so my
branding was in alignment with that my
LinkedIn page was targeting campus
recruiting positions it was in my
headline it was in my About section
it was showcased in my content I was
engaging with other recruiters and so
all of that was in alignment um keyword
optimization so if you all are familiar
with how Google searches work right a
lot of those searches are based on the
amount of keywords that come up when you
search those things so it's the same
thing as it relates to these applicant
tracking systems that I talking about as
well as LinkedIn if your profile does
not include keywords from the positions
that you're looking for you're missing
out that's where that first LinkedIn
webinar is gonna come in really helpful
because I'll showcase you that step by
step how you can do a better job with
that I'm and then the networking piece
so the relationship building same thing
as a business you have to network to get
customers you have to network to build
partnerships and you have to keep track
of these relationships if you just find
them and meet them and have one sale
that's fine but your best customers are
often your return customers so same
thing goes with you and your job search
make sure that you're following up and
keeping in contact with the connections
that you are making okay let's skip this
so that we can get through it but
accessing the hidden job market so this
is a couple of tools that you can use a
couple of resources Google Alerts are
great if there are a couple of companies
that you specifically want to work for
feel free to set up Google Alerts for
those so that when they're mentioned in
the news you have a better idea of that
a couple of cool things that I've been
able to use Google Alerts for is typing
in like certain companies in Atlanta so
if certain companies move their
headquarters here I know that they're
about to hire so instead of waiting for
them to post those jobs online I'm
connecting with those recruiters in
advance and saying hey I saw on this
article that you all are moving to
Atlanta if you're looking for anybody
who does this I'd love to share my
resume if you're interested this is this
is easy but it's next-level thinking
it's it's putting yourself in a position
to be successful before everybody else
even has a chance to making sure that
you're following these companies on
LinkedIn as well as their employees a
lot of times employees will post jobs
before they're even posted online you'll
see that quite frequently and a lot of
times they'll even include an email so
you can submit your stuff directly to
that person which means
don't have to worry about an applicant
tracking system a lot of companies will
allow you to sign up for their their
hiring newsletter so they'll send you
updates any time they're hiring for new
roles conferences and job fairs are
always always helpful I got my very
first full time job at a conference so
obviously it works and the networking is
huge so we have about four minutes left
I want to answer as many questions as I
possibly can
let's see how many we can get through
give me one second okay so how to reach
key people successfully they reply to
you so one try to personalize it as much
as possible you can even filter on
LinkedIn for people who completed
nanodegrees at Udacity so obviously they
have to put that on their profile first
but you can filter their school by
Udacity that's an easy way to find
something in common you may have went to
the same University you may have the
same philanthropic causes you may
volunteer with the same organization
read their About section see if you have
anything in common there those are great
ways to do it I tell people all the time
offer to buy them lunch offer to buy
them coffee and some people will say I
don't have the money I can't afford that
if you don't start prioritizing
investing in yourself you'll always have
that mindset so I may not necessarily
have 30 dollars to spend on lunch but if
that $30 leads to a job that pays me ten
twenty thousand dollars more it's worth
it even if it doesn't happen this
go-around I may be able to pull on that
connection in the future so you have to
get in the habit of investing yourself
investing in yourself obviously you all
paid for these nano degree programs and
are attending this workshop so I know
that that is something that you do so
don't forget to do those things just as
a way to sweeten the pot for them does
LinkedIn recommendations help absolutely
so I want you all to think about this
for a second if you're going to buy
something on Amazon
and you let's say you want a new shower
curtain you're gonna go there what's the
first thing you're gonna do you're going
to go and check the reviews because we
want to know if other people also vouch
for this product we don't want to just
believe the seller because they're
trying to make money and so your
LinkedIn recommendations are oftentimes
at the bottom of your profile and these
are people who are vouching for your
work and so for a recruiter or for an
employer let's say you posted something
on LinkedIn about I don't know computer
vision you posted something about your
thoughts on this one specific topic and
somebody's like oh we need somebody to
do that let me go to their profile then
they go to your profile and you followed
all the tips and tricks I showed you in
that LinkedIn webinar and then they see
at the very bottom that there are 12
people vouching for your work at that
point they're going to be more likely to
reach out to you to where you're
starting to get offers for interviews
without ever even having to apply so
you're on the completely other end of
this hiring process you have a lot of
power to leverage that means you can
negotiate salary better you can do all
of these different things better than
being on the desperate end of needing a
job and feeling like you have to rely on
other people for help so LinkedIn
recommendations are great how to balance
being humble or boasting about your
skills I mean that's it that's it that's
a tough question that's that's gonna
depend on the person that you're talking
to some people want you to brag
especially in the hiring process they
want to know why you're good enough for
that position but that's that's really
case-by-case basis um sharing the slack
we don't really share the slides but we
will upload the recording so be on the
lookout for that it may be within the
next couple of days I'll probably post
that in student hub this week to let you
know that the recording is finally up I
don't know what you're asking
what about consultancies can you clarify
that question I will publish the
presentation it will be recorded on that
web webinar playlist is it okay to call
the companies to get information about
available positions um I think you know
there's no harm in trying
nobody's gonna be like this guy or this
girl called me and they wanted to know
like
that's not going to ever work against
you I just don't know that a lot of
companies are going to be willing to
share that information what you're
probably going to experience is you're
gonna call and ask and they're gonna
forward you to their website to check
there so I think it's fine to try but I
don't know that you're gonna experience
too much success with that okay
sorry that I had to run through that as
quickly as possible but I hope this was
helpful I would love to see some of you
sign up for coaching sessions either
with me or any of the other career
coaches around these topics but as we go
into this new year stop relying on those
old habits if all you're doing is
applying for jobs online it's kind of
lazy go the extra mile focus on quality
over quantity only apply for jobs that
you really really want and put in the
work to build those relationships and
get to that point
don't just type in the job title you
want and apply to everything and hope
for the best that's how you end up back
in the same position with a job that you
hate and so you don't want to kind of
rush into a job that's why it's
important for you to focus and find
those jobs that you really want and even
some of those ones that are a little bit
of safer bits but maybe ones that were
gonna help you get to your next level
yeah thank you all I really appreciate
you all showing up this is the highest
attended webinar that I've done with
Udacity since April so I appreciate you
all being engaged I appreciate you all
committing to this I see that there are
a couple of other questions that I'm not
going to be able to get to as I
mentioned feel free to schedule a
follow-up call if you want to go ahead
and jump into a student hub really
quickly I'll be there to answer
questions please keep those questions to
like easy quick questions if they're
more in depth schedule a coaching call
so that we have a full 30 minutes over
the phone individually to talk through
that but thank you all so much I am
gonna work to get this uploaded once
it's processed and uploaded to YouTube
so if you want to kind of rewatch it
feel free to do so if you want to
schedule a coaching call as I mentioned
you can schedule with me any of the
other coaches will be able to help you
with this but once again thank you so
much and be on the lookout for our
future events that we have coming up so
thank you all I look forward to
you all soon